what's up I'm Marlon Wayans and I'm
going undercover on the Internet and
it's actually me first up Instagram are
you on tour love the stand up Pete
Martinez 91 I'm glad you asked are you
just so happen to have a few dates right
here I'm gonna be on tour at Tommy T's
and Pleasanton August 23rd through the
25th September 6 to the 8th I'm at the
funny bone in Columbus Ohio September
14th
big show at the MGM National Harbor
theater in DC there's more but I'm not
but yes come see me when it's season 3
of Marlin interesting question you gotta
ask NBC cuz they cancelled damn I was
excited what's the holdup holdup is if
you don't get two black guys to spend
seven hours of makeup and then work 17
hours after that and sleep for only two
and a half hours a night for about 65
days
chances are you got to pay them
something just not a movie to do
complain everyone over here going crazy
about white six to possibility
what about Hornet house 3 those movies
were the best parenting movies ever
we need more I'm probably not gonna do a
haunted house 3 I'm tired of parody I
want to do movies with storylines and
characters you care about I think it's
my way of maturing I'll find a way to do
silly movies with more depth next bro
you look outstanding for your age any
tips yes here's my tip smile a lot and
don't do crack something about crack
makes you look really old how about a
series about you and your siblings
growing up how about we pitch that [ __ ]
to Studios and they all said no what of
the Hollywood y'all need to drop a movie
soon or an album because
we look like for R&B singers hopefully
we'll drop it will be soon but it's hard
to get for crazy it's hard to get for
crazy do anything together we could
barely eat dinner together anyone here
Eminem mentioned Marlon in his latest
song yes I did he said that at that at a
scary movie let's make a scary movie
like Marlon Wayans and then Kanye
mentioned me in my last one I pull up to
the door like Will Smith and Martin do
we have a problem
or better yet Marlon and I didn't know
if he meant like was he mad at me was he
beating with me it was not like a
subliminal did he catch me looking at
Kim's ass
or was he mad that I said something
special or maybe I'm just looking too
deep into all this [ __ ]
and Kanye loves me but I've been
extremely jealous of my brother's Biggie
mention them major pain like Damon
Wayans go down very even like don't
bring your girl around me I think I went
to a different song but my point is I
wanted biggie to mention me but I wasn't
good at famous at the time so he knew
damn it is Facebook Derrick Garcia when
y'all stop making the scary movies they
went down big time
the best ones were Part one and Part two
y'all need to doing another one all
together soon yeah we knew they would
suck when we left but they made a lot of
money off him so we have our pride but
they made money so maybe we'll do part
six
now that the Weinsteins are probably
gonna be in the jail cell
Marlon you and Michael Blackson to do a
movie together like a comedy version of
bad boys I think it'd be off the chain
you can also have your brothers Keenan
and Damon help you write a script waddle
Keenan and Eamonn help right it's great
for Michael Blackson oh thanks how about
we get Damon Blackson and Keenan
Blackson to help write Michael Blackson
a script but yes I do think Michael
Blackson is funny and maybe we'll do
something you know try to think of a
plot right now maybe he's a Somalian
terrorist
and I'm a cop on a missing African seat
somewhere or maybe I adopt a kid and I
think it's gonna be a little African kid
but they sent me this a grown-ass okay
so now I'm stuck with this grown ass
goddamn African man little potential
y'all do something up next you too
marlon wayans that's a youtube channel
yes I do
I got a dope video my son playing
basketball love I just want y'all
opinion is he mine or not because I can
never do any of this [ __ ] that little
boy is doing let me know am I the father
or not check my youtube channel mall
away at you too hey Marla who was your
favorite DBZ character I'm gonna say old
with the DBZ I'm 47 I'll watch my son
play with that [ __ ] man ain't nothing
compared to a Chiappa number and it
wasn't even a battle of the stars no bet
all the fields panel battled the Earth's
I don't know but it was a Japanese anime
and look just like Dragon Ball Z King
[ __ ] did here
what's your new movie I'm just curious
and the movie naked was really good
thank you
this movie's called sextuplets and I
play a guy named Alan who goes on a
journey to find his birth family and he
finds out that he's one of six six
tuplets so it's me starring me
co-starring me and three more minutes
and then I'm some of the extras too
there's a lot of me watch movies dope
loyal Philly fan show is hilarious
Mullen has me die in every episode how
any prayers and prepositions you got me
all up in here god damn just a run-on
sentence on the wood he's starting an
Endon show is hilarious period Marlon
has me dying every episode period my
show is underrated when I was too early
while the good black shows go off early
like the game Everybody Hates Chris
smart guy and this and don't forget
Marlon Oh
it cancelled me real quick you knew I
was a black show only one guy canceled
quicker than me was the new Roseanne
they cancelled her like like her name
was the pizza reddit
how did marlon wayans end up and requiem
for a dream he auditioned for it five
times because darren aronofsky was like
I don't want anybody from the Frog
Network in my great artistic movie and
then Marlon auditioned for it five times
and he was like wow dude on the Frog
channel
WB Performing Arts High School LaGuardia
baby class of 1990 always Twitter
seriously this actually me Marlon in a
world of reboots and sequels why there
no don't be a menace to it could follow
look Dawg finally getting out of Hood
and going to college where he meets a
wealthy white girl possibly played by
Anna Faris she needs a way as my movie
don t that's a terrible I want you to
read whatever you wrote me back and then
ask yourself should we do it don't be a
minutes - who had the better sneakers
Marlon Runaways mothers or will from
Fresh Prince well being that Will Smith
was in bel-air I'm pretty sure Uncle
Phil could buy him a lot better shoes
then I could buy as the poor kid that
works part-time at a newsstand but Molly
had that fire some corny about wills
sneakers it was nice but he laced them
too tight it be suffocating to me I know
swag I let my [ __ ] breathe submit Marlon
what is your favorite song now my
favorite song right now is I don't have
one but there's one song I cannot get
out
my role my role do the hotel boyo right
till I can Nomura got LaFollette in the
bath
I don't know none of words pronounced in
my head again marlon wayans it shorty
immortal further is he ultimate villain
behind all those scary movies like a
dope cannabis puppet master always he
the hero that the world needs now either
way I don't want to believe his story is
over
you're definitely smoking pot right now
as you type that I know we did I smelled
the cannabis lube is great boom Netflix
needs to add the Wayans brothers show in
their lineup what do you think I think
Netflix should add everything lands
because it's a great place to go just
have a wins corner posted hey I want to
thank everybody for your questions the
good ones the bad ones and the peace
love and I'm stuck
you
you